this week on wheel of science we're
talking the moon
i don't even have to say anything neil
you know where my mind is love me some
moon
be it crescent half or full exactly
you're watching wheel of science welcome
to wheel of science the interactive show
where we
answer your questions about the universe
i'm your host chuck nice and i don't
answer your questions
the one the only dr neil degrasse tyson
answers your questions what's up neil is
that your attempt to sound like more
than one person
with the voices in my head it sounds
like more than one person to me
that's for sure it looks like i
recognize that background there
uh where in the world is neil degrasse
tyson
i'm in my place i'm in the cosmic office
my office at the hayden planetarium
right here in new york city oh oh oh the
cosmic crib
that's right it's the crib all right
neil what time is it my friend
it's been the wheel time you heard the
man spin that wheel
[Music]
this is jeremy locus who wants to know
this if the moon's orbit was further or
closer to us
what kind of effect would it have on our
planet
very nice so one of the things that
matters most
about the moon and its distance is how
powerful it is
on tides the tides are
very sensitive to the distance the moon
is from
earth and so the moon were much closer
for example when the moon first formed
it was 20 times closer than it is today
and that would have made it 20 times 400
tides that were 8 000 times stronger
than they are today
can you imagine that water just
pulverizing coastlines
back and forth by the way the moon is
spiraling away from us
at a few inches per year and in response
earth's rotation is slowing down
and eventually we will be tidally locked
with the moon
only ever showing the same face and when
that happens tides will no longer slosh
in and out from the ocean shores wow who
knew that the moon and my wife have so
much in common
both inching away from me a little bit
at a time
all right neil you ready for another
question bring it on
hair melon rudd wants to know what
material substance or
natural resource is worth extracting
from our moon
will humanity ever do that so the moon
all evidence points to the moon having
formed
from a proto-planet side-swiping earth
side-swiping and ripping up our outer
layers
and those outer layers reforming into
the moon
we have a very good sense of this
because the moon does not have much of
an
iron core so it's not made of the same
stuff everything else is it's made of
this selectively
filtered material called earth's crust
so if you go to the moon it'll look a
lot like earth's crust
that's not very interesting you don't
have to go to the moon to get earth's
crust stuff
plus it's not going to have much metals
either there's not not much iron we'll
get the iron from earth
here's what the moon has that we don't
have helium-3
these are particles that stream from the
sun
and they get embedded in the lunar soils
and they just stay there
it's called the regolith the lunar
regolith and it just stays there
helium-3 is an important ingredient in
thermonuclear fusion
and if you're going to have
thermonuclear fusion reactors to
generate energy
you would want helium 3 to help that
process out otherwise it takes a lot of
energy to get to that to get to the
final result
in your thermonuclear fusion so if you
mined the moon for helium 3
you could become possibly the world's
first trillionaire first trillionaire
i am on it to the moon alice
to the moon who knew he was threatening
her with great wealth
and you know what we're going to take a
break right now and you millennials can
go look up that
dated ancient reference and figure out
why it'll never happen in today's
society
we'll be right back with more wheel of
science
thanks to wix for sponsoring this
episode of wheel of science did you know
that our fastest rockets take days to
reach the moon
but using artificial design intelligence
on wix
will allow you to build a website in a
fraction of that time
yeah like this let's do it with adi
you just answer a few questions and your
site is
almost ready to go go to wix.com
go slash star talk and begin your
site right now welcome back to wheel of
science
time to jump right in and get another
question you ready neil spin that wheel
[Music]
raymond bernadicius wants to know this
why did we stop exploring the moon
neil that's cause you think and so do so
many other people
that we went to the moon to explore the
moon
we went to the moon to beat the russians
back then the soviet union
we they were they were beating us in
everything and
we might remember ourselves in america
as pioneers of the space race but
practically every decision we made was
in response
to something russia either did or said
they were going to do
so we were not proactive
in that race we were reactive and the
biggest reactive thing we did
was we're going to the damn moon which
we did
and then we found out that russia was
not going to the moon
we were done and you talk about
exploring the moon
ask yourself how many scientists did we
send to the moon
one and uh what moon mission was that on
the last mission so evidence that it
really was never about
exploring the moon and all the science
experiments that the astronauts did
nearly all of whom were ex-military
pilots
the experiments they did were because we
got nasa to have
our little experiments piggyback
this hundred billion dollar enterprise
that's not why we went to the moon so
that's it you want to go to mars
if some rogue country puts military
bases on mars
we're there if not i don't really see it
happening
anytime soon wow it's good to see that
nothing has changed
hey it's caption time here on wheel of
science neil we took this picture of you
and put it up for people to comment on
and here are our favorites i wonder
what caption they will give the photo
and the other kirk or picard hmm
that i wonder what caption will give the
photo it's very meta
that's that's a i like that but
you got to stay in the in the geek world
and i gotta say kirk or picard
but i might add kirk picard
or janeway oh how enlightened of you
neil
time now for our wheel of science poll
and the question is where
should we explore next moon or mars
answer the poll right here and neil moon
or mars
do it all better than a nike commercial
don't just do it
do it all it will take billions
of years for the earth and the moon to
tidally lock
but it takes just a few minutes to build
your personal or professional website on
wix using adi
just answer a few questions choose a
template and a layout
decide if you need business features
like an online store
and go live with a click we don't have a
store at wheel of science but if we did
i'd be selling designs to stop the moon
from tidally locking with the earth
yeah and i also would be selling bridges
yeah
but that's just me i suggest anyone else
cheat and just let the adi make a
website for you
how cool is that hey if you want more
design customization
you can use the regular wix editor and
get exactly the site that you want
use all fonts all the motion backgrounds
and
all the visual web goodness you can
handle
go to wix.com go slash start talk
and begin your site now
hey that's our show as usual we have to
say thank you to the one the only doctor
neil degrasse tyson thanks neil
i'm i remain your humble servant well in
that case paint my house